all right so this is one last job this
is served the heist film episode of
adventure tire which is what's so great
its IQ predictor is gonna be a heist
episode anywhere in the near future even
ever in adventure time is just what it
starts off with just like we had your
toner you need to reassemble the team
and you just see them getting these
colorful characters to get it just I
love it I love how I could just do
anything so pretty much what I just said
Jake's daughter has been Jake jr. has
been kidnapped and since he has to pull
off one last job which is the they had
to rob this great bait wasn't even a
thing at the ultimate sugar or something
I you know you scared it out with me
what God okay so you know they have to
get the Baker's crystal and he assembles
this team of really strange out their
characters and goes in they get it but
it turns out it was all just a plan done
by Jake jr. cuz she knew that he used to
be like a robber and she just wanted to
be like him and he's saying no no that's
bad don't do it again and she's already
thinking of the next con and that just
makes him prouder and kind of a mixed
message but who cares yeah yeah this was
just fun it's just fun seeing an
adventure time do a heist movie you know
it's fun seeing you know the different
people's powers and stuff I loved was it
Tiffany who is that the demon uh when
you know you seen the pictures of all
the characters you see Tiffany and with
this style you don't know exactly always
what you're looking at so you see what
looks like a girl but has a little bit
of a mustache growing and so when she's
about to talk I don't know it's it's
gonna be like you know a guy's voice are
a woman's voice or a teenage girl's
night it's like I don't know and then we
have like whatever a six-year-old or
whatever do the voice it's just
hilarious to not remember
Tiffany wait we talked to me before yeah
see someone well Jake was going out with
Rainicorn and Finn went and made Tiffany
his new best friend no no no no ha yeah
I'm not the only one
Jake convinces Finn and rate according
to hangouts then Jake starts getting
jealous so he goes through his phone
which by the way also brings up the
flying lettuce brothers occasion this
and he finally stops on Tiffany and they
come out in they're both playing viola
and he's like why would I be upset by
Tiffany cause Tiffany's up boy
oh so Tiffany was Jana it's so dumb okay
so we talked to Vinny before so maybe it
was never a voice choice as I thought
but I did pick up that was the same
voice as the cat assassin and I don't
think so
no I looked around it does it does I was
looking at okay hold on what isn't that
the girl from the city of these I I
looked I couldn't find a connection yet
I could be wrong and do a ton of
research in the time I will say this
with the time it takes to make episodes
that's I'd be shocked if not if that
voice never changed I mean that's like
that that's a while for that voice to be
like that cuz it sounds like yeah I mean
it sounds identical yeah but so okay
know what so as funny as I thought it's
still fun to see him do a heist movie
it's fun too I love that guy what was it
the spell of his face yeah whatever I
love the way they illustrate that I like
to do how the lettuce brothers can form
a voice by you know one key get what
half of the voice one can get the other
half and then they do it together yeah
you know I thought that was really
clever
so yeah I just thought was funny and
again I love how you can just go into
this I mean just go into where a heist
movie now it's just totally have fun
with it and I like Finn's one-man band
with the ya know organized sound too
you know spell keys gonna play it and
make some dumb sounds but then it goes
boom Oh froze it down starts squashing
it I mean they always go like that one
extra step to make it funnier you know
it's it's noise rock yeah and it like
Sonic Youth or melt banana stuff like
that or any Audi from home movies again
oh yeah you made it last time so I just
decided to make another reference oh but
no I did I thought what I thought was
great fun uh again it was another one
that was just okay for me I did like the
flying lettuce brothers one thing I
really liked about the flying lettuce
brothers was just their name flying
lettuce brothers because they don't look
like lettuce didn't put blades of grass
yeah neither of them fly um now we know
of yeah that's true um also I was never
too impressed with Jake jr. like out of
the designs it she looks like a part
wrinkled pickle with hair well I think
that's part of the fun is that they're
all so cute and here's something that's
just so distinctly not cute it's just
these wrinkles you know Ivy it just
looks like you know I wanted to do the
one that looks like a giant roll of like
poo it did I thought that was pretty
close this is a multi-coloured poo sort
of no no I it was another one of those a
two in a row for me it was kind of just
like that it's okay it's cute it's not
bad I don't hate it but again I just
kinda really wasn't that drawn in I did
love BMO how he says I'm not a snitch
but the second that like Finn shows up
it gives it all the way he's out with
his gang it's just like okay
I wondering if Finn actually believes or
not if he's like you know okay she's
just being silly you're like oh he's
doing that cool I am I'm doing this oh
you know like if he even cares I I do
find it funny though because way back in
the earlier days of watching the be logs
with you you were talking about Jake
maybe having a dark side yeah because he
did have a pass you know robbing things
but
before that you were before anything was
ever given away really about it you kind
of were already questioning it well you
can see seems like someone who like like
we even dumped up before ladies always
involved just in himself and doesn't
care about others and fitness or the
only thing close to caring about another
person even then you know during the
episode reason the hot tub and
everything you know it's kind of like he
really had to convince himself oh yeah
like this is important so yeah it kind
of makes sense I mean he always sir has
that attitude but I like how you called
it beforehand which is nice okay cool
I'll let you compliment me fine
plus what this episode also does for all
the times I shouldn't say all the times
for when I feel that Jake is being like
a selfish ass or anything like that this
is one of those where it shows that he's
not always a selfish ass well that he
does have a caring side that his kids
have brought out more from him than
anyone else possibly could and I think
it's it shows that he has grown since
being a father hmm
ya know there's something kind of cool
like when he grows you know when they're
driving off and he grows into that giant
that he's just like you know going after
the truck it's like you know just asking
for Jake jr. I've been pounding bridge a
junior yeah that's kind of cool um the
one another see I'm just saying that
really maybe laughs hard is when
whatever that kwik-e-mart plate was
place was or whatever the boss was levy
she'll say you know I'm gonna see the
water it just like doesn't even open the
door just crashes through it walking at
that very slow pace remember that place
no I don't know how would I remember
that place yeah but you have to own up
when you do a laugh that's not laughs
worthy you hypocrite laughing she's
laughing at you again yeah but that's
dessert as I said something funny no you
did it and actually it's really funny
because you brought up this episode
before the ghost princess episode the
guy who killed himself by eating all the
cheese oh that's right that's where they
oh is that where they got the cheese
that's where he's like my life is a fart
this is like you know there's bull we
are like 127 they're so damn many of
these episode it's hard to keep them all
in remember them all right now we're at
in total they just put out episode 162
god it's so great I can't believe how
strong so it's good I'm happy it's going
so strongly you know it's still LA I
know I'm a broken record but it's still
so amazing how continually fresh and
funny and surprising they can make this
show even they'll like the last two
episodes which I was not a fan of well
when I see which were not as impressive
to me or I didn't sit there go oh my god
I love this episode they were still fun
episodes ya know and they weren't
predictable yeah the only one that the
only episode I can't stand still is
glitches to glue issue other than that
even to this point in time seeing all of
the episodes glitches the glitch is the
only one that I just don't like all the
other ones I've liked so far in one way
yeah yeah even if it's not like a
stronger episode or it's like and I've
seen that before whatever it's like it's
yeah there's nothing all four there's
nothing that's like oh that was a waste
of time I wish I never saw it I gain
nothing by watching yet you know so um
no I agree I'm still I'm always
constantly impressed with the show or
just me